i'm not privy to all the inside
information but it was a matter of
warners and fox uh splitting up the pie
appropriately and
clearances for many many people you know
when you have writers and actors and
directors on and on involved best boys
whatever uh it gets very complicated pam
do you remember what it was like the
first day of shooting of batman
oh i certainly do
because i put on that costume
and walked out of my dressing room on
this large stage and walked toward the
light started the camera thinking
now will that crew will they accept me
as batman or will everyone begin to
laugh
well it was really
a dramatic moment for me because
everyone was sort of in awe and they
they all accepted me as batman and it
was great batman was an intense kind of
social satire
for the adults and a wonderful adventure
for the kids
it it was good because i had a chance to
play that kind of absurd comedy and uh
batman
has
had a certain longevity that very few
shows have
which gives me access to people
the nicest thing that can happen to an
actor is to be recognized to be
given a kind of affection or love and
people have really done that were you a
fan or are you a fan of comic book
superheroes
well batman was never in my sense a
superhero
he never had any kind of super
uh attributes um you know he didn't bite
on it on an electric chord and then
become kind of
like um extremely a clever uh a fast and
strong no he just was an ordinary guy
who developed his own mental capacities
and physical
and got a chance to run around fighting
crime
24 7. he was crazy
so what about thinking funny in uh
family guy how do you think funny there
well you've got to think really funny
there because
the character i play the mayor
mayor west
of quahog
is
totally uh crazy i mean he's a bonkers
he's um you know i'm able to
do a little sense memory and use maybe
the
the most idiotic or quirky parts of my
personality
and magnify that somehow
for the mayor
and it seems
seems to work are you at all struck by
the multi-million dollar pay packages
that the actors can now get for these
performances like iron man for example
well yes i was struck i was struck in
the heart and it just hurts um
you know i think if if they can get that
kind of pay
they wouldn't be getting it unless they
brought in people to buy tickets and i
think it's all kind of there's a balance
there but i'm struck yes because
we didn't receive that kind of payment
although i must be honest
when i did the batman feature
they paid me very well
for those times
and that's why i can wear these
expensive duds and things